(electronic music)
- When I look at a floppy disk today,
I look at something that's valuable,
and that I used, and yet,
when most people look at it,
they'll look at it almost as a joke.
(phone ringing)
Floppydisk.com.
I'm the last man standing
in the floppy disk business,
because I basically forgot
to get out of the business.
In this office, we're in a time warp.
Manufacturing of the diskettes is over,
and so all of the diskettes
that will be made have been made.
I'm desperately trying to acquire
as many diskettes as I possibly can.
All kinds of disks come
flying into our doors.
From time to time, a commercial
recycler will call me up
and say, “Hey, I have somewhere between
35 and 50,000 disks.”
We sort them; we run them through
a process to erase the information.
Once the diskettes are
reformatted and relabelled,
we're able to resell them.
We do sell to the U.S. Government.
There are a number of applications that
the government has that call
for the use of a floppy disk.
The old saw is if it
ain't broke don't fix it.
Most of our business is for
commercial and industrial use,
whether they be embroidery machines, ATMs,
avionics for airplanes, those
machines are still around,
and they're going to last
for quite a few more years.
The floppy disk business
will not be around forever.
No, I won't be around forever either.
(laughing)